[음악]
ا 일정 때문에 나왔는데 날씨가 진짜
좋은 거 같아요. 근데 너무 더운 거
같습니다. 어 날씨가 거의 한 30도
거의 40도에 육박할 정도로 매우
더운 거 같습니다. 그리고 특히
5월이 제일 덥대요. 네. 그래서
보통은 두바이 여행을 그니까 우리나라
기준으로 좀 겨울철에 많이 온다라고
합니다. 그래서 그때는 밤도 되게
날씨가 좀 춥추울 정도로 뭐 현지인분
얘기 들어 보면은 좀 이렇게 전기
장판을 틀고 잘 정도로 춥다라고
합니다. 그래서 오늘 일단 두바이 있
제일 좀 보고 싶은 데가 그 팜
근처예요. 팜을 어떻게 만들어 놨는지
그전에 영상으로만 봤었는데 어 실제로
가서 좀 보고 싶고 이게 어떻게
보면은 그 인공 섬같이 만들어 놓은
거잖아요. 보면서 뭐 여러 가지
아이디어를 좀 많이 얻을 수 있지
않을까
[음악]
싶습니다. 네. 지금 여기 보이는
곳이 JBR 마리나 지역입니다.
위치에 사람들 많이 보이시 텐데 관광
명소로 유명해요. 네. 그래서 여기
보시면은 인공섬을 만들었어요. 그래서
최대 규모로 만들었고 그래서 팜
주메라가 이쪽에 있습니다. 야자수를
입무형처럼 만든 인공섬입니다. 그리고
바다에 아무것도 없는 곳에 순수하게
만든
인공섬이고 인류 최대 토목공사로
기네스북에 올라가 있는 그런 섬이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 제가 여기
타고 있는 아인 두바이 같은 경우에는
높이가 엄청 높아요. 거의 6 빌딩
정도의 높이입니다. 한 250m 뭐이
정도 수준인데 진짜 엄청 높습니다.
사실 제가 고속봉증이 있는데 지금
벌벌 떨면서 얘기하고 있는데 아무튼
세계에서 가장 큰 그런 관람차라고
보시면 될 거 같아요. 두바이의 눈을
뜻하는 어 그런 뜻이라고 보시면 될
거 같고 정말 두바이는 세계 최대
규모로 이런 건축물들이 좀 많이
생겨나는 거 같습니다. 저기도 제가
한번 이따가 들려 가지고 한번 좀 볼
건데 쌍용 건설이 이쪽에 좀 건축을
많이 했어요. 이런 기념비적인 어
이런 의미 있는 건축물들을 좀 많이
짓고 있습니다. 그리고 지금요
아이두바인 같은 경우에는 현대
건설에서 예 시공을 해 가지고 같이
쌍용 건설도 같이 참여를 했어요.
상징성 있는 이런 건물들을 우리 한국
건설사가 직접 이렇게 지어 가지고
하고 있습니다. 그리고 그 브루즈
칼리파 같은 경우에도 삼성물산이
건설해 가지고 하고 있고 두바이에
이렇게 진짜 우리나라 건설사들이 좀
많이 참여를 했습니다. 네.
네. 아, 저는 아틀랜티스 로얄에 와
있습니다. 쌍용 건설이 건설한 호텔에
왔는데 와, 저는 진짜 살면서 이렇게
멋진 호텔은 처음 온 거 같아요.
정말 와라는 소리밖에 안 나옵니다.
진짜 럭셔리한 그런 호텔이라고 보시면
될 거 같고 일박에 비수기 때 한
150만 원 정도 한다라고 해요.
그리고 이제 성수기 때에는 그니까
이제 11월부터 한 2월까지는 한
300만 원이 넘는다라고 합니다.
근데 그때 그 돈 주고라도 예약을 못
한다라고 합니다. 이만큼 되게 인기
있고 세계의 럭셔리한 리치들한테 되게
인기 있는 호텔이라고 합니다. 와,
진짜 이게 말이 안 돼요. 여러분들
여기 진짜 두바이 오시면 여기 꼭 와
보세요. 진짜 대박입니다. 네바이
하면 사막이죠? 그래서 저는 사막을
가려고 지금 차에 탔습니다. 뭐 사실
살면서 사막을 본 적이 없습니다. 뭐
이번 기회 사막을 실제로 좀 보고
어떻게 생겼는지도 한번 좀 보도록
하고 이따 기회되면 낙타도 한번 타
볼 예정인데 두바이의 사막도 어떤지
여러분들 기대하셔도 좋을 것
[음악]
같습니다. 여러분들 제가 사막에
왔는데 정말 말이 안 됩니다. 제가
살면서 사막을 처음 봤지만 뭔가 되게
황홀한 거 같아요. 네. 정말 말로
표현할 수 없을 정도로 정말 놀랐고
어 여러분들 만약에 두바이를 오거나
아니면은 뭐 사막을 오실 기회가
있다라고 하면 꼭 사막 꼭 오시길
바랍니다. 두바이가 정말 뭐 초고층
빌딩도 많고 되게 컨텐츠가 많은
곳이긴 하지만 특히이 사막에 대한
매력도가 너무 좋은 거 같아요.
여기저기 여행 가면서 사막을 간 적은
없잖아요. 정말 두바이는 이런 사막에
대한 어 되게 좀 특별한 그런
콘텐츠가 있는 곳이 아닌가 그렇게
생각이 됩니다. 나중에 가족들이랑
오고 싶네요. 너무 좋은데 애들 너무
좋아할 것
같아요. 네. 여기가 이제
엑스포시티인데 여기가 2020년부터
이제 개발이 완료된 곳입니다. 그래서
여기를 기점으로 지금 우측으로
보시면은 지금 황무지 상태인데 여기에
이제 공항이 들어옵니다. 이거
개발되고 난 뒤에 어떤 모습일지 정말
너무 궁금해요. 네. 그래서 제가
실제로 좀 찾아왔는데 아무것도
없습니다. 네. 진짜 길지 않은
미래에 여기도 엄청나게 개발될 것으로
좀 보고 있습니다. 지금 여기
보시는게 알막 공항입니다. 그래서
기존에 이제 왕족들이나 아니면 류얼
패밀리들이 이제 이쪽 공항을
이용한다라고 합니다. 지금 우리가
지금 두바이에 와서 만났던 여러
사람들이 이쪽을 하나가지 다 얘기를
했습니다. 그래서 여러분들 만약에
두바이 투자 계획이 있으시다라고 하면
이쪽 일대를 한번 좀 보시면 좋을 거
같아요. 네. 그만큼 좀 여기 투자
가치가 많이 있다라고 하는데 어
앞으로 지금 아무것도 없어요. 네.
뭐 건물 몇 개 좀 보이고 아무것도
없긴 한데 앞으로 여기가 좀 어떻게
변할지 지켜보면 좋을 것 같습니다.
두바이가 빠르게 개발됐던 이유 중에
하나가 지금 뭐 인프라 개발이라든지
부동산 개발 이런 이슈들도 있긴
하지만 무관세가 있대요. 그래서 여기
항공이라든지 뭐 항만 같은데 무관세
때문에 이런 택가리를 하러 많이
온대요. 그런 부분에 있어서 아무래도
자유롭게 좀 열어 놨기 때문에
두바이가 좀 빠른 속도로 개발이
됐다라고 합니다.
[음악]
네. 저는 세계에서 제일 높은 브루즈
칼리파에 와 있습니다. 정말 높아요.
네. 높고 828m라고 합니다. 롯데
타워가 한 555m인데 그거와
비교해서 진짜 월등이 높다라고 볼 수
있어요. 그리고 이거 여러분들이
아셔야 될 거는 삼성 물산에서 건물을
신축했습니다. 우리나라 기업이 어
신축했다라고 알고 계시면 좋을 거
같고 어 지금 밤 시간인데 사람들이
되게 많아요. 정말 세계 각지의
사람들이 지금 두바이에 오면은 꼭
와야 될 관광 명소 중에 하난 거
같습니다. 좀 시간이 지나면은 저기
앞에서 분수 쇼를 하거든요. 분수
쇼도 되게 진짜 장간인데 두바이 오신
분들이 브루즈 칼리파뿐만 아니라 여기
분수 그다음에 여기 앞에 두바이 몰이
있어요. 두바이 몰은 세 개에서 가장
큽니다. 네. 그래서 그 정도로
두바이에 오면은 꼭 와야 되는 명소
중에 하난 거 같아요. 저는 살면서
이런 야경을 또 처음 봤습니다. 정말
화려하고 정말 멋지고 말이 안
나옵니다. 네. 이게 사실 영상으로
담길지 모르겠습니다. 네. 그래서 그
정도로 정말 화려하고 좋은 것
습니다.
[음악]